bonjour à tous bienvenue salaire de
parlement hebdo bienvenue sur les
chaînes parlementaires à mes côtés
céline bittner bonjour s'est dit bonjour
mickaël esnault l'actus cette semaine
après le choc des attentats le
gouvernement était attendu sur les
propositions des annonces des moyens et
des hommes l'arsenal anti terroriste a
été renforcée l'armée parvient à sauver
des postes mobilisation également pour
l'école l'accent est mis sur la laïcité
au total plusieurs centaines de millions
d'euros seront engagés dans ce contexte
les français apprécient l'action du
couple exécutif un bond historique pour
françois hollande qui retrouve des
sommets atteints avant son élection de
2012 manuel valls gagne lui aussi des
points à gauche comme à droite et plus
cette semaine le président de la
république s'est adressé aux
parlementaires et il a lancé son plan
pour la transparence de la vie publique
transparence pour les élus pour la vie
économique plus de règles de
vérification pour commenter cette
semaine notre invité est david rachline
bonjour alors vous êtes un peu un
symbole un symbole car vous êtes l'un
des deux premiers sénateurs de
l'histoire du front national plus jeune
sénateur de la vème république à 27 ans
vous représente également cette nouvelle
génération frontiste voulue par marine
le pen
et puis vous êtes aussi un petit peu
cumulards puisque vous êtes également le
maire de la ville de fréjus
alors je voudrais qu'on regarde ensemble
cette image regardez c'était le 1er
octobre 2014
votre premier jour au palais du
luxembourg et en tant que benjamin où
vous étiez secrétaire de séance
plusieurs sénateurs ont alors refusé de
vous serrer la main
est-ce que ça se passe mieux aujourd'hui
vous écoutez les jeux se passe très bien
j'étais pas de toute façon venu au sénat
pour me faire des amis je suis là pour
défendre des grands électeurs qui m'ont
fait confiance qui ont fait confiance à
mon mouvement et qui considérait qu'il
était logique somme toute que plusieurs
millions d'électeurs soit représenté au
sénat nous ne sommes que deux d'ailleurs
je pense que
ce n'est pas le reflet de ce que nous
représentons réellement mais il n'en
reste pas moins que depuis les choses se
passent bien on vous sert là bas dans
les couloirs oui absolument la plupart
il reste toujours quelques secteurs mais
peu importe je suis pas là pour leur
plaire donc ça ne me dérange pas là vous
connaissez le principe de l'émission va
passer en revue tout ce qui s'est passé
cette semaine dans l'actualité va
commencer par le lundi françois hollande
et manuel valls ont la cote c'est un
bond de popularité record pour
l'exécutif 21 points pour le chef de
l'état 17 points pour manuel valls il
récolte en fait les fous de la gestion
de la crise qui vient de se dérouler
jean baptiste daoulas le rebond est
spectaculaire d'après un sondage ifop
fiducial pour paris match la cote de
satisfaction de françois hollande gagne
21 points à 40% le président de la
république n'avait pas atteint un tel
niveau de popularité depuis février 2013
regain de confiance également pour
manuel valls +17 points
le premier ministre est à 61 % de bonnes
opinions
un rebond lié à la gestion des attentats
terroristes de charlie hebdo et de la
porte de vincennes clairement les
français considèrent que françois on a
été à la hauteur qu'il a réussi à gommer
les critiques récurrentes en termes de
manque d'autorité en termes de manque de
fermeté en termes d'atermoiements c'est
maintenant un président qui incarne
union fois nationale et qui a mis fin
aux landes bashing parce que ce qui est
absolument nouveau dans ce sondage c'est
bien sûr la progression de françois
hollande à gauche en gagne 30 points
chez les sympathisants socialistes
mais c'est aussi et surtout pour la
première fois il progresse nettement
les sympathisants de droite et du centre
la séquence est délicate pour
l'opposition difficile de critiquer
françois hollande
après deux semaines d'union nationale
toutes les bulles spéculatives ont
vocation un jour exploser donc nous
verrons quand nous reviendrons dans une
période un peu plus classique j'allais
dire où les français regardons l'heure
ces jus lors leur sujet de préoccupation
quotidienne tels que l'évolution du
chômage
l'évolution de la situation économique
et sociale de notre pays en 1991
françois mitterrand avait connu
également un rebond au début de la
guerre du golfe
mais cette lune de miel avec l'opinion
n'avait duré que quelques mois
david rachline cette question va
peut-être vous surprendre mais faites
vous partie de ces français qui ont
changé de regard sur le passé de la
comique en tout cas on peut dire que il
est quand même normal que les français
se solidarise de leur gouvernement
en pareille situation et il est vrai
nous l'avons dit d'ailleurs clairement
que françois hollande a plutôt bien géré
ces moments éminemment douloureux pour
notre pays néanmoins désormais il va
falloir laisser passer le temps du deuil
est maintenant se concentrer sur les
véritables propositions dans notre pays
a besoin pour pouvoir prévenir ces
menaces ramata venir j'imagine pour
françois hollande et manuel valls
oui dans le cadre de la gestion encore
une fois de ce drame dans le cadre de
l'hommage qui a été rendu je crois à
l'exception de l'exclusion du front
national et marine le pen de la fameuse
marche
il n'en reste pas moins que globalement
je considère qu'il est normal que les
français se rassemblent autour de notre
pays de son gouvernement autour de la
république française et de ces valeurs
vous ne regrettez pas ne pas avoir
participé à voir mais nous allons s'est
ouvert mais vous a dit venez vienne
qu'il veut mais nous avons participé aux
marches dans la paroisse il n'y a pas
que paris il est aussi moi j'étais à
fréjus avec plus de 5000 fréjusiens sur
la place de la ville sur la place de la
mairie bureau dans la grotte photo denis
tous les dirigeants tous les dirigeants
du mcs la farine tous les dirigeants du
front national était partout dans les
provinces de notre pays
je crois que on ne va pas à une
manifestation dans laquelle nous ne
sommes pas invités je pense que c'est
somme toute logique et je regrette qu'à
cette occasion le gouvernement a exclu
25% des français en tout cas une
responsable politique majeur qui
n'aurait pas dû être exclu de mon point
de vue l'une des seules quand même
personnalité politique qui n'augmentent
pas qui stagne dans les sondages c'est
marine le pen alors pourtant sur le fond
à la période pourrait sembler propice
aux thèses du front national pourquoi ça
ne profite pas votre parti vous savez
nous étions encore une fois dans la
période du
dans la période de l'hommage et c'était
bien normal vient aujourd'hui le temps
de la réflexion des propositions le pen
s'est exprimée s'est exprimée seulement
il ya quelques jours vendredi dernier je
crois à l'occasion d'une grande
conférence de paix non non je crois pas
du tout encore une fois à vendredi
dernier elle a commencé à s'exprimer sur
les propositions qui est ton qui sont
les nôtres et dont on va avoir
l'occasion probablement de reparler
et je crois que c'est là dessus que nous
allons être jugé je ne me fais pas de
souci je vous signale au passage qui a
eu un sondage dans le figaro il y à
quelques heures pour dire que 45% des
français elle pouvait éventuellement
voter pour le front national donc nous
ne sommes pas si isolé que ça le gros
test pour l'exécutif pour vous pour
toulon 2 finalement le parti politique
c'est quoi c'est la prochaine
législative partielle qui aura lieu dans
le doubs c'est là dessus qu'on va juger
si l'exécutif réussi vous savez les
législatives partielles réagissent aussi
en fonction de considérations locales et
je crois pas qu'il faille se concentrer
là dessus en revanche la prochaine un
test national pour la prochainement
devant nous en tirons un certain nombre
de conséquences bien sûr mais ça n'est
pas l'alpha et l'oméga de ce qu'il faut
considérer politiquement aujourd'hui en
revanche la prochaine élection
importante majeur c'est les élections
départementales qui vont avoir lieu en
même temps au niveau national et là nous
verrons véritablement où on est
l'opinion et je crois qu'on peut
s'attendre à de très bons résultats pour
notre mouvement bien sûr alors ce lundi
c'est aussi la colère de plusieurs pays
musulmans contre la une de charlie hebdo
à gaza en iran tchétchénie ou encore on
a gagné ce temps des milliers de
manifestants ont protesté contre la une
de l'hebdomadaire satirique représentant
le prophète mahomet des drapeaux
français ont été brûlés au pack us
pakistan à niamey au niger des français
ont été invités à ne pas sortir de chez
eux après des manifestations violentes
elle reste que charlie hebdo a bien fait
de publier nouvelle fois la caricature
de mahomet à la lune ou alors est-ce que
c'était une provocation
vous savez je crois que notre république
notre pays est attaché à la liberté
d'expression et à ce titre charlie hebdo
publié ce qui lui plaît et ce qu'il a
envie de publier néanmoins effectivement
ça a suscité un certain nombre de
réactions je crois que par certains
aspects elles sont excessives mais nous
ne pouvons pas demander à tous les pays
du monde à voir
mêmes pratiques que nous d'avoir le même
ton dans les médias dans la presse
d'avoir cette même liberté d'expression
ce serait mieux si c'était le cas ça
n'est pas le cas nous devons en prendre
acte de simplement
mais faire respecter en tout cas en
france ce principe clair de liberté
d'expression qui m'apparaît essentiel de
5000 personnes en tchétchénie ça vous a
surpris ou pas oui contre la mort oui
oui c'est beaucoup
indéniablement et je crois que les
gouvernements de ces pays serait bien
inspiré de rappeler qu'il faut respecter
les autres nations du monde respectait
la france pour ce qu'elle est je pense
que c'est un point important est ce que
c'était aussi le symbole finalement
d'une montée d'un sentiment anti
français
c'est surtout la démonstration
manifestement d'une montée d'une forme
de radicalité dans la pratique des
religions et je crois que par certains
aspects nous pouvons nous en inquiéter
nous voyons ce développement faramineux
de l'islamisme radical en série par
exemple en irak aussi mais pas seulement
au yémen et ailleurs et je crois qu'il
faut que là aussi nous en tirions un
certain nombre de conclusions et surtout
que nous protégions notre pays contre
ces menaces
l'arrivée mardi manuel valls emploie des
mots qui fâchent c'est une formule choc
lors de ses voeux à la presse le premier
ministre a dénoncé un apartheid
territoriale sociale ethnique pour des
cas la situation des banlieues
une petite phrase qui a fait bien sûr
beaucoup réagir rinne benameur près de
deux semaines après les attentats du 7
janvier
comment lutter contre la division de la
société française comment rebâtir une
unité nationale manuel valls lors de ses
voeux à la presse dresse un lourd
constat oui c'est l'aîné jour où
souligné beaucoup des maux qui rongent
notre pays ou des défis que nous avons à
relever la relégation périurbaines les
ghettos ce que j'évoquais en 2005 déjà
un appart hyde territoriale sociale
ethnique
quelques heures plus tard le premier
ministre répond à françois de rugy lors
des questions au gouvernement
avec la même gravité dire que
pour ce qui concerne l'école où les
quartiers où le sentiment de relégation
ou de ses négations dire qu'il faudrait
résoudre ces questions en quelques jours
en quelques semaines n'aurait aucun sens
nous ne répondrons d'ailleurs pas à
l'exigence des français aux quatre
colonnes le mode apart est utilisé par
manuel valls divise
si on prend le mot apartheid pour ce qui
veut dire c'est à dire un développement
séparé des gens au sein d'une même
communauté nationale
c'est en partie ce qui est en cours en
france la politique d'apartheid en
afrique du sud c'était une politique qui
visait à séparer les gens leur interdire
de l'or mais toutes sortes de barrières
dans la progression dans la société
c'est parce qu'a voulu la république
française françois hollande a chargé les
deux assemblées de réfléchir aux moyens
de renforcer l'appartenance républicaine
notamment grâce au développement du
service civique
les deux chambres ont jusqu'au mois de
mars pour faire des propositions
il dira des choses fortes pour être
entendu c'est un peu la méthode que vous
aussi vous pratiquez au front national
oui en choisissant les termes que nous
employons et surtout moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le fond des choses
qu'est ce qui fait que nous en sommes
arrivés en effet par certains aspects
une séparation
on va par cauet il noté vous reprendrez
se mouvoir prendrait pas ce terme de on
peut parler en revanche de séparation
dans un certain nombre de cas entre les
populations on peut parler de
communautarisme et qu'est ce qui fait
que nous en sommes arrivés là c'est la
politique appliquée par l'ump et le ps
depuis maintenant des dizaines d'années
ce sont eux qui ont malheureusement
amener ses revendications communautaires
à être exaucé ce sont eux qui ont
produit cette situation et je crois que
on ne peut pas d'une erreur par des
ministres comment vous a choqué au mode
apartheid
il est assez il est assez choquant mais
ce qui est encore plus choquant encore
une fois c'est de voir manuel valls
aujourd'hui dénoncer une situation qu'il
a avec ses amis ump et ps d'ailleurs lui
même créée et je crois que c'est cela
dont il faut parler mais alors vous même
j'ai gardé un petit peu les chiffres
mais dans votre ville de fréjus vous
avez réduit
eh bien les subventions aux associations
est ce que ça ça ne provoque pas de fête
une ghettoïsation des quartiers dont
vous savez à fréjus j'ai simplement fait
en sorte que les centres sociaux
fonctionnent mieux et en effet 50 % les
subventions pour les centres nous avons
mis fin à un certain nombre de dépenses
inutiles et nous avons fermé même un
centre social pour ancrer pour créer à
la place une maison de quartier
qu'israël grâce au service jeunesse de
la ville grâce au ccs beaucoup plus à
même de traiter les différents problèmes
qui se posent à ce quartier mais de
manière générale je crois que avant
toute chose et avant toutes
problématiques liées aux centres sociaux
et à la question sociale il faut
rappeler un certain nombre de valeurs
clair que sont l'autorité la discipline
et l'ordre public qu'est le combat
contre le communautarisme et je crois
que ce sont des valeurs qui
malheureusement n'ont pas suffisamment
été rappelé par le gouvernement et par
l'état ces derniers mois et ces
dernières une proposition de malek
boutih qu'on a vu dans le reportage
c'est la mise sous tutelle de l'état de
certains quartiers où seriez peau non
non non je ne suis pas pour la mise sous
tutelle d'un certain nombre de quartiers
je crois que les administrations locales
et les collectivités territoriales
doivent se gérer parce qu'ils sont élus
pour le faire les maires dans la plupart
des classes sont à la hauteur de la
responsabilité qu'est ce que quel que
soit d'ailleurs leur étiquette politique
ce n'est pas la question il essaye avec
des moyens toujours moins importants à
cause des économies budgétaires qui sont
faits justement par l'état sur le dos
des collectivités territoriales de gérer
la situation qu'est ce que vous proposez
concrètement alors pour éviter justement
cette ghettoïsation
vous savez il faut lutter contre le
communautarisme de manière ferme dès le
plus jeune âge et je crois que ça c'est
éminemment important il faudra aussi
lutter contre le communautarisme c'est
rappeler les valeurs de la république
c'est ne pas céder aux revendications
communautaires c'est ne pas permettre de
piscine est par exemple les menus dans
les cantines et tout ce dont on a
l'habitude de parler depuis maintenant
des années
les burqas qu'on a le droit
manifestement en tout cas de cette date
et loire de continuer à
il ya un certain nombre de lois mais
dans les foyers revenir sans laïcité
soit que ça n'est pas appliqué et donc
c'est le respect total de la laïcité
encore une fois ça n'est pas
suffisamment le cas aujourd'hui et je
crois que l'ump et le ps est
particulièrement ce gouvernement porte
une responsabilité majeure dans
l'absence de respect de la laïcité d'un
module d'amo sur le mot apartheid qui a
été prononcée est ce que la manuel valls
a brisé l'unité nationale qui étaient en
cours mais de toute façon il est normal
que les débats dans une démocratie dans
la république reprennent mais l'unité
nationale n'aurait peut-être pas dû être
brisé de cette manière là avec ce mot là
un visage a fait la une de l'actualité
ce mardi celui de lassana bâti lit ce
jeune malien de 24 ans est devenu
officiellement français cet employé de
l'épicerie père cacher avait aidé des
clients à se dissimuler dans la chambre
froide lors de la prise d'otage de la
porte de vincennes manuel valls et
bernard cazeneuve le ministre de
l'intérieur ont salué son acte de
bravoure vous qui êtes contre
l'immigration est ce que lassana bâti
dit c'est pas la preuve que
l'immigration peut aussi être une chance
pour la france
vous savez moi je suis pour le contrôle
aux frontières d'abord et pour réduire
en effet drastiquement le nombre
d'étrangers qui rentre sur notre sol car
il en rentre encore 200 mille par an je
crois que c'est beaucoup trop et que ce
n'est pas d'ailleurs sans lien avec la
situation de communautarisme qui se
développe dans notre pays mais dans ce
cas bien précis il est bien évident que
est d'ailleurs moi je crois que la
mission de la nationalité s'hérite ou se
mérite
en l'occurrence en l'occurrence il la
mérite et c'est bien normal qu il qu'il
puisse le devenir français mais ça ne
doit pas être automatique comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui je crois qu'on devrait
être beaucoup plus raisonnable dans le
nombre de
deux guides accusés sur la nationale 7
610 personnes contractent en 2014 ce qui
est beaucoup moins ce qui est beaucoup
trop toujours pas ce que vous savez nous
n'avons plus les moyens de cette
politique nous n'avons plus les moyens
d'accepter l'arrivée sur notre
territoire de 200 mille immigrés de
chaque année je crois que la
démonstration en est faite que tous les
politiques s'accordent à dire que
l'immigration est trop importante dans
notre pays
mais l'ump comme le ps n'en tire pas les
conclusions et ne régule pas aux
frontières
cette immigration la saison nous avons
là en effet un vrai sujet ce contrôle
aux frontières qu'il va falloir rétablir
dans les plus brefs délais ah oui venir
justement sur les mesures contre le
terrorisme a été prise par manuel valls
nous sommes mercredi
quinze jours après vie d'abord les
attentats qui ont ensanglanté paris les
mesures étaient attendues manuel valls a
annoncé un renforcement considérable des
moyens humains et matériels
un plan d'urgence pour lutter contre le
djihadisme de détail avec marie vraiment
c'est un gouvernement uni derrière son
premier ministre qui est venu présenter
l'ensemble des mesures pour lutter
contre le terrorisme
un gouvernement uni est entièrement
mobilisé pour ce faire des moyens
importants sont débloqués ce sont 420 5
millions de crédits d'investissement
déguisement de fonctionnement qui seront
consacrés au cours des trois prochaines
années
ce plan de renforcement 425 millions
d'euros donc sur trois ans pour
surveiller près de 3000 personnes
impliquées de près ou de loin dans des
filières terroristes
une enveloppe budgétaire qui permettra
notamment de gonfler les effectifs de
renseignement 1400 emplois rien que pour
le ministère de l'intérieur
mais les effectifs seront également
renforcés à la défense bercy et à la
justice d'ailleurs dans le cadre de la
lutte contre la radicalisation 60
millions d'euros seront mobilisés et 60
au money
musulmans seront recrutés pour les
prisons un fichier placée sous le
contrôle d'un juge sera créé dans lequel
seront obligatoirement inscrire toutes
les personnes condamnées ou
judiciairement mis en cause pour des
faits le thé rose c'est donc un fichier
spécial de personnes condamnées pour
terrorisme qui va voir le jour afin de
permettre leur surveillance quant à la
peine d'indignité nationale qui fait
débat le premier ministre n'a pas
tranché il a dit ne pas vouloir agir
dans la précipitation et a confié aux
deux assemblées le soin de formuler des
propositions complémentaires
est ce que les mesures annoncées par
sont suffisantes pour lutter contre la
menace théorie bien sûr que non et la
véritable question est pourquoi ont-ils
supprimer des postes de policiers et de
gendarmes dans les dix dernières années
pourquoi les moyens des renseignements
ne sont pas à la hauteur ne sont plus à
la hauteur de la situation
pourquoi avons-nous fait des économies
sur les moyens de l'armée depuis
maintenant plusieurs dizaines d'années
je crois que c'est ça la véritable
question est évidemment qu'il nous faut
renforcer les moyens de la police et de
la gendarmerie dans des proportions
considérables évidemment qu'il faut
renforcer les moyens de l'armée et pas
seulement faire cesser la baisse des
moyens renforcés les moyens de l'armée
qui est dans une situation aujourd'hui
au dramatique où est ce que vous faites
là des centaines de milliers d'euros
d'économies à faire vous voulez on
pourra en rediscuter sur l'immigration
sur l'union européenne sur toute une
série de sujets vous savez que dans ce
domaine là les propositions en tout cas
de notre côté ne manquent pas mais il y
as des as certain nombre d'éléments sur
lesquels on ne peut pas transiger et je
crois que malheureusement pendant de
trop nombreuses années des économies ont
été faites sur ces postes là ça n'aurait
jamais dû être le cas maintenant
d'urgence il faut renforcer les moyens
je le disais de la police du
renseignement de l'armée parce que nous
le voyons bien c'est indispensable
est-ce que sur le fond vous serez
d'accord avec un patriot act à la
française
bon c'est pas exactement ce qu'on y met
à l'intérieur ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
va falloir renforcer dans des
proportions considérables non seulement
les moyens que je viens d'évoquer
mais encore agir sur l'éducation agir
sur la justice pour lutter contre les
récidivistes mais j'ai posé en ce sens
une question à la garde des sceaux qui
vient qui avait supprimé récemment
des mesures contre les récidivistes
alors que contraire pas encore pas
encore mais j'espère que j'espère que
j'en aurai une bientôt dans tous les
domaines il nous faut il nous faudra
agir malheureusement c'est le laxisme
qui a triomphé
que ce soit dans l'éducation dans la
justice c'est le laxisme qui a triomphé
dans tous les domaines y soient trop
d'angélisme bien sûr et pas de prise de
conscience de la réalité de la situation
pas de prise de conscience du
développement ou que nous avons du nord
dénoncé de ce fondamentalisme islamique
qui se propage dans un certain nombre de
nos quartiers et dans un certain nombre
de nos villes ça ne veut pas dire que
tous les musulmans évidemment sont de
dangereux citoyens mais une petite
partie font la démonstration qu'ils sont
dangereux et nous devons mettre tous les
moyens pour lutter contre ça n'a pas été
le cas jusque là malheureusement alors
que nous nous avions prévenu alors losio
la dignité déchéance de nationalité y
avoir du calendrier le conseil
constitutionnel se prononcer ce vendredi
sur la nationalité d'un franco marocain
condamné pour terrorisme déchéance de
nationalité validée par le conseil
constitutionnel est une bonne nouvelle
bien sûr qu'il faut déchoir de leur
nationalité
ceux qui commettent des actes graves et
même ceux qui sont des délinquants
récidivistes et même toute une série de
gens qui n'ont pas être sur notre
territoire
je crois que c'est la pure logique nous
devons choisir ce dont il peut le faire
que quand il ya la double nationalité
quel conseil constitue d'ailleurs bien
voulu aller plus loin en tout cas on est
si déjà on faisait cela ce serait déjà
pas mal
et si déjà ceux qui ont la double
nationalité de toute façon nous nous
sommes contre la double nationalité et
nous croyons qu'il faut choisir et qu'on
ne peut pas que ce principe de double
nationalité n'est pas n'est pas sérieux
mais pour ceux qui aujourd'hui ont la
double nationalité bien sûr qu'ils
doivent être déçus c'est une évidence
absolue
eh bien il faut prévoir un renforcement
du dispositif judiciaire des peines
qu'ils soient plus importantes
aujourd'hui quand on a cantonné à donner
et national par exemple
peu importe les mots mais aujourd'hui
sachez que lorsque on est condamné à une
peine de moins d'un an de prison on ne
la fait pas parce qu'on manque de place
dans les prisons parce que notre
dispositif carcéral et judiciaire n'est
pas à la hauteur de la situation
je crois que dans ces domaines là il va
nous falloir travailler sérieusement et
en tout cas il faudrait que ce
gouvernement le fasse sur le plan
militaire maintenant françois hollande
a tenu un conseil de défense ce mercredi
l'armée a réussi à sauver des emplois
7500 postes de militaires seront
finalement épargné sur les trente-quatre
mille supprimait ce que l'armée a encore
les moyens de ses ambitions et les
moyens de défendre
finalement notre pays entre les
opérations extérieures est aujourd'hui
le plan vigipirate renforcé bien sûr que
non et nombre de responsables de l'armée
se sont exprimés à différentes occasions
et ont tiré la sonnette d'alarmé nous
mêmes depuis des années moi au sénat
j'ai eu l'occasion d'intervenir sur le
projet de loi de finances dans ces
domaines là et nous voyons bien que non
seulement les moyens ne sont pas à la
hauteur mais qu'en plus ils étaient
drastiquement réduit ces dernières
années alors qu'au contraire il eût
fallu les augmenter ou en tout cas les
maintenir moi je crois que il faut que
les moyens soient renforcés qu'il faut
que l'état fasse un véritable effort
dans ce domaine là parce que nous ne
pouvons pas en même temps essayer de
dire et de rassurer les français sur
leur sécurité sur la situation
notre pays nous en demandons toujours
plus à l'armée alors qu'ils ont toujours
des moyens sont très courtes la loi sur
le renseignement qui est prévue pour
mars ou la vôtre et ou pas écoutez nous
verrons ce que nous voterons nous irons
dans le détail pour vérifier si si les
moyens sont à la hauteur de la situation
ce qui est sûr c'est que je suis
partisan d'un renforcement très
important les moyens et nous aurons
l'occasion de faire un certain nombre de
propositions y compris au sénat
d'ailleurs service civique au service
militaire vis militaire obligatoire
service militaire service militaire pour
2,3 pour quelques mois
mais évidemment que cette cette
suppression n'est pas allé dans le bon
sens et c'est indispensable
jeudi c'est l'école qui est en première
ligne
laïcité autorités citoyenneté trois mots
qui résument le plan de la jat vallaud
belkacem pour réaffirmer les valeurs
républicaines à l'école 250 millions
d'euros seront investis sur trois ans
les détails avec marie prévost on a
laissé l'école la communauté scolaire
les enseignants devenir le réceptacle de
tous les maux de la société
alors qu'elle devrait son protégé pour
protéger chaque élève un constat d'échec
mais la volonté de rectifier le tir
la ministre de l'éducation a présenté
les grandes lignes de son plan pour
remettre les valeurs républicaines au
centre de l'école ce sont 1000 formateur
aguerris qui seront formés sur la
laïcité et l'enseignement moral et
civique avant la prochaine rentrée
scolaire
mille inspecteurs professeur
documentaliste ou chefs d'établissements
qui seront formés pour répondre aux
questions relatives à la citoyenneté la
laïcité et à la lutte contre les
préjugés
une journée de la laïcité sera désormais
célébrée dans tous les établissements
chaque 9 décembre journée anniversaire
de la loi de séparation des églises et
de l'état
tous les établissements devront
également participer aux commémorations
patriotiques et mettre en place de
nouveaux rendez vous la semaine de
l'engagement et la semaine de la lutte
contre le racisme et l'antisémitisme
tout comportement contraire à ses règles
fera l'objet d'un signalement
systématique de la part de l'enseignant
au directeur d'école ou chefs
d'établissement et ces derniers seront
invités à y donner suite
systématiquement
voilà donc le volet sanction de ce plan
qui veut également asseoir l'autorité
des professeurs
l'exécutif souhaite un recours plus
systématique aux mesures de réparation
et de responsabilisation sortes de
travaux d'intérêts généraux pour les
élèves toutes ces mesures s'inscrivent
dans le cadre d'un nouveau parcours
citoyen du cp à la terminale
au total 300 heures d'enseignement moral
et civique mais également aux médias et
à l'information des mesures
consensuelles qui ont un coût de 150
millions d'euros sur trois ans
est ce que c'est le bon moyen de
réaffirmer la laïcité à l'école où il
faudrait aller encore plus loin il faut
aller plus loin
évidemment et je crois que c'est dès le
plus jeune âge qu'il faut lutter contre
les communautarismes et nous nous avons
dix pour démontrer cela qu'il fallait
rétablir l'uniforme à l'école
nous avons dit aussi qu'il était c'est
une bonne proposition bien entendu les
signalements dont on parle qui vont être
c'est au rectorat
ça n'est pas suffisant il faut convoquer
les parents systématiquement il faut
signaler sa au procureur de la
république pas au recteur même si ça
n'est pas incompatible avec l faut des
mesures il faut des mesures mais dès le
plus jeune âge
dès le plus jeune âge dès lors que les
enfants sont à l'école et qu'on voit
qu'il ya un certain nombre de dérives il
faut des signalements qui soient des
signalements opérant qui puisse
permettre une réaction de la part de
l'autorité publique de la part de la
justice éventuellement à l'égard de
l'enfant bien sûr mais l'égard des
parents quand c'est pour les très jeunes
je crois que c'est très important
on n'en fera pas l'économie et
malheureusement je crois qu'on ne va pas
assez loin
aujourd'hui dans ces domaines là donc un
manque d'autorité selon vous aujourd'hui
de la part il faut aussi réapprendre dès
le plus jeune âge l'éducation civique il
faut aussi peut-être un petit peu de
morale à l'école
aujourd'hui on sait que là une partie en
tout cas des enfants sortent de l'école
sans savoir parler le français
et c'est absolument dramatique il faut
donc renforcer lors du tour de france et
les parents aussi plus selon vous oui
mais bien sûr bien sûr qu'il faut le
responsabiliser les parents je vous en
parlais à l'instant et je vous disais
que le signalement doit être frais
auprès de probablement du procureur de
la république pour qu'il puisse agir sur
sur les parents et pas seulement sur les
enfants puisque ce sont les parents
aussi qui sont chargés qu'aux charges et
de leur éducation et ses dérives
naissent aussi en partie à cause d'un
certain nombre de parents qui sont
défaillants il faut bien dire je vais de
la laïcité le 9 décembre parce que vous
veillez à ce qu'elle soit célébrée dans
votre ville à fréjus mais moi je
respecte les lois de la république
évidemment et elle vous plaît et lorsque
ce sera voté puisque ce sera
probablement le cas alors comme partout
en france la loi de la république sera
respectée évidemment inbev qu elles vous
plaisent et peut-être d'abord
et peut-être même d'abord dans ma
commune c'est à dire écoutez moi je suis
favorable à ce que dans ma commune les
lois de la république soit respectée
donc peut-être d'abord et avant tout
donc vous verrez également à ce que la
laïcité soit toutes les lois autour de
la laïcité soit mise en place
williams mise en oeuvre parce qu'elle
existe aujourd'hui je pense à
l'interdiction du voile des signes
religieux
vous savez la question des mères voilées
pour les sorties scolaires bien sûr
comment est-ce que vous appliquez
sachets ou bien sûr mais nous sommes
vigilants ne rencontre pas nous
rencontrons pas particulièrement de deux
problématiques liées à cela
à fréjus en tout cas mais je sais que
nombre de maires sont confrontés à ces
situations c'est difficile il faut que
j'aie envie or l'état soit aux côtés des
collectivités locales aux côtés des élus
locaux pour leur apporter une aide pour
pouvoir traiter ce problème parce que ce
n'est pas le maire d'une petite commune
seule sans moyens qui est capable de
répondre à cette à ces problématiques
donc il faut là encore que l'état
accompagne les collectivités pour faire
respecter la loi et je crois que là
encore le signalement et j'en termine
dès des instituteurs et des directeurs
d'école est très important ils doivent
participer agir aux côtés des élus
locaux la sphère cahuzac était nous sont
passés par là françois hollande veut une
république plus transparents encadrement
des nominations contrôle des lobbys le
chef de l'état a annoncé une série de
mesures pour renforcer la déontologie
dans la vie publique
on écoutera soldes pour éviter que des
manquements ne soient connus
postérieurement à l'entrée en fonction
des intéressés il devra être procédé à
des vérifications avant tout les
nominations les plus importantes
je sais aussi que les assemblées
travaille sur des propositions par
rapport aux candidatures aux élections
ensuite les nouvelles règles
déontologiques seront étendues à tous
les acteurs publics fonctionnaires comme
magistrat des projets de loi seront
déposées au parlement et seront bientôt
inscrit à l'ordre du jour enfin il
faudra encore rendre plus claire la caf
ou confection des lois et des règlements
pour un meilleur encadrement des groupes
de pression les loin se multiplient pour
renforcer la transparence dans la vie
publique et pourtant l'impression en
tout cas
français ont l'impression c'est un petit
peu un voeu pieux est ce que la
république exemplaire voulue par
françois hollande c'est pour maintenant
c'est surtout un peu tard parce que
après le nombre d'affaires qui sait il
faut bien le dire multiplier depuis ces
derniers mois particulièrement au parti
socialiste et ça ne sont pas les seuls
d'ailleurs puisque d'autres sont apparus
au grand jour particulièrement à l'ump
je crois que c'était nécessaire et donc
évidemment qu'il faut aller vers
davantage de transparence est une
évidence absolue mais il ya aussi à
faire dans le choix des hommes et les
mouvements politiques y compris leur
direction devrait peut-être être
davantage vigilants sur les gens qu'ils
choisissent pour aller se présenter au
front national aussi l'arrivée des
affaires les déboires avec des avec des
élus lesquels par exemple je normal que
vous n'ayez pas honte extrêmement rare
contrairement à l'ump est la différence
d'ailleurs que nous avons c'est
d'ailleurs là la différence d'ailleurs
que nous lorsqu'il y a une problématique
avec un élu nous en séparent ont
immédiatement ce n'est pas toujours le
cas du parti socialiste qui pendant des
mois à garder monsieur cahuzac comme
ministre me semble-t-il
il en est de même pour tous les élus qui
ont été condamnés à différentes
occasions madame andrieux était encore
récemment vice présidente du conseil
régional en reco nivet 20 qui a préparé
le plus vite possible de la personne qui
a commis une fois lors il faut envoyer
un message clair il faut que les parties
prennent les responsabilités qu'ils
écartent les brebis galeuses si on peut
dire et encore une fois il ya un vrai
travail à faire dans le choix des hommes
et des femmes qui nous représente et qui
sont les représentants de la république
alors j'ai regardé un j'ai cherché sur
le site internet du sénat
votre déclaration de patrimoine n'a pas
encore été publié vous venez d'arriver
mais est-ce que vous pensez que voilà ce
genre de d'exemple ou de procédures qui
peuvent aller dans la bonne voie ce que
vous êtes prêts à aix à nous dire par
exemple l'état de votre patrimoine
aujourd'hui sur ce plateau
oui oui oui mais vous savez à 27 ans à
27 ans il est quasiment inexistante
la vérité donc par conséquent j'ai pas
du tout de problème avec ça j'ai envoyé
évidemment le document en question qui
sera publiée je pense dans les prochains
jours dans les prochains mois c'est pas
moi qui gère ça mais moi j'ai pas du
tout de difficulté avec ça et je pense
que chacun peut publier son patrimoine
si ça vous paraît indispensable mais le
véritable problème c'est de savoir si on
s'enrichit grâce au mandat qui est le
nôtre c'est ça le vrai problème et je
pense que c'est là dessus que nous
devrions agir en tout cas avoir des vues
allez on en vient tout de suite à notre
nouvelle rubrique de parlement hebdo
c'est la loupe du skal avec un autre
partenaire du figaro le scan point fr
nous accueillons le rédacteur au chef de
ce site jaime jara c'est jimmy qui a
effectué encore très chargé cette
semaine décryptées
bonjour david rachline c'est mon le
sénateur frontiste que l'ex responsable
de la communication numérique du front
national que je vais interroger
aujourd'hui je vais essayer de devoirs
avec vous qu'elle est là comment la
communication numérique du front
national a évolué et notamment ces
dernières semaines on a l'impression que
c'est devenu plus compliqué de gérer
toutes les équipes les expressions
numérique des cadres du front national
j'ai plusieurs exemples le premier c'est
ce tweet de jean marie le pen qui a été
publié le 9 janvier il faut rappeler qu
on le taxe c'est le jour du double
assaut à dammartin-en-goële et sur la
porte de vincennes à l'épicerie cacher
il ya ce tweet qui sort sur le twitter
de jean marie le pen qui calment vote le
pen
gardez votre calme votez le pen c'est
une fin flagrant délit de récupération
politique
est ce que vous regrettez ce type de
tweets devrait d'abord moi je suis pas
jean marie le pen donc vous poserai la
question à jean marie le pen vous dire
parce que oui ça c'est un fait mais ce
que je peux vous dire en tout cas c'est
que notre stratégie sur internet et la
stratégie que nous avions mis en place
dès l'élection présidentielle en 2012 a
fonctionné nous sommes les premiers le
premier parti politique sur internet
nous avons une efficacité record dans
ces domaines là
et nous n'avons pas de difficultés
majeures en l'occurrence ce tweet est ce
qu'il était dans une ligne de
communication consciente du front
national quelque chose de volontaire la
ligne de communication et qui a été la
note c'est celle qui a été développé par
marine le pen pendant pendant ces
semaines c'est semaine difficile pour
notre pays
jean marie le pen à sa liberté de ton il
est un il est habitué à en user
d'ailleurs il faut bien le dire et c'est
sa responsabilité mais ce qui est ce qui
est certain c'est que la ligne du
mouvement politique la ligne stratégique
l'orientation clair c'est marine le pen
qui la fixe et je crois qu'elle est
l'occasion de le faire et c'était
parfaitement clair autre exemple alors
autre exemple cette vidéo de
l'eurodéputé chauprade dont on parle
beaucoup cette semaine et on va regarder
quelques extraits tout de suite on nous
dit qu'une majorité de musulmans et
pacifique
certes mais une majorité d'allemands
l'été avant 1933 et le national
socialisme allemand
une majorité de russes de chinois de
khmers étaient pacifiques avant qu'il ne
réalise d' abominables crimes au nom du
communisme
marine le pen s'est désolidarisé
d'aymeric chauprade en m'interdisant
carte du front national de diffuser
cette vidéo pourtant marion maréchal-le
pen s'est fendu d'un petit tweet pour
diffuser cette vidéo alors on a
l'impression qu'il ya deux camps un peu
qui se dessine sein du front national
dans quel camp vous serez tués vous pour
commenter le tweet de tel responsable
police nationale
ça promet encore cette semaine la
réalité c'est la suivante
marine le pen a été élue avec 100 % des
voix au dernier congrès c'est elle qui
fixe la ligne c'est elle qui fixe le cap
politique du front national elle a eu
l'occasion de dire qu'elle était en
désaccord avec une partie en tout cas de
la vision d'aymeric chauprade
les choses sont donc éminemment clair le
front national sa ligne a été rappelé
par la présidente et le seul digne et il
n'y a qu'une seule ligne au front
national c'est extrêmement clair et moi
je suis en l'occurrence sur la ligne du
front national seulement jeune femme sa
place au front national aujourd'hui mais
encore une fois c'est à lui de nous dire
si je crois d'ailleurs pouvoir dire que
à 95% il est d'accord avec la ligne de
marine le pen et avec la ligne
stratégique politique qui est celle de
notre présidente
il faut encore une fois un petit peu de
discipline dans un mouvement il faut
respecter une forme d'autorité on en
parlait tout à l'heure mais dans un
parti politique c'est valable aussi et
donc il est normal que marine le pen
remette de l'ordre quand c'est
nécessaire
une polémique a également éclaté dans
votre ville de fréjus travaillez vous
avez pris la décision en descend je
crois de supprimer l'abonnement de la
médiathèque à plusieurs quotidiens
nationaux dont libération et le figaro
alors vous invoquez des choix
budgétaires c'est c'est tout à fait
compréhensible et vous avez le droit en
tant que maire de faire ça mais vous
opposants locaux ont organisé une
manifestation pour dénoncer une atteinte
au pluralisme de la presse oui est ce
que vous n'avez pas regretter cette
décision après les attentats ont frappé
la rédaction charline vous savez
d'ailleurs bon hein les adversaires
politiques du parti socialiste qui
étaient présents ce jour là étaient 10
et l'immense majorité des fréjusiens a
bien compris que c'était pas le maire de
fréjus qu'avait fait ce choix il y avait
un budget acquisition journaux de 11000
euros il est passé à 7000 euros dans le
cadre des économies
j'ai désendetter la commune qui était la
cinquième commune la plus endettée de
france 2 8 millions et demi d'euros sur
la première année il ya beaucoup de
collectivités
peut-être qu'ils feraient bien de s'en
inspirer on est passés donc 200 soit 160
abonnement à sans abonnement pour une
raison simple c'est qu'il nous fallait
faire des économies encore une fois et
donc la direction de la bibliothèque a
choisi les
les journaux les magazines qui était là
lui qu'on a du mal et vous remettez le
figaro breveté libe c'est ceux qui sont
les plus consultés qu'ils ont été
conservés maintenant encore une fois ci
ça fait plaisir au parti socialiste ou
si ça fait plaisir à un certain nombre
de personnes
s'il faut remettre le figaro pour leur
faire plaisir moi je suis une bonne
composition donc et mais nous verrons
encore une fois mais si les fréjusiens
le réclame vous savez ils peuvent aussi
les gens du parti socialiste qui allez
lire libération n'est pas spécialement
le figaro je pense
ils peuvent aussi aller dans un kiosque
et puis ce qu'ils ont des indemnités
d'élue importante au madame di méo et je
crois présidente de commission au
conseil régional elle a des indemnités
importantes et peut aller soutenir
libération en allant acheter dans un
kiosque ou même en s'abonnant ce qui se
joue les portes ouvertes merci vous
dirigez la gym portes ouvertes
voyez une des conséquences évidemment un
ce qui m'a très lourd c'est les films
qui ont été déprogrammés ces derniers
jours par des mères vous êtes maire on
vous demandera votre avis dans un
instant c'est le plus de l'hebdo pour
l'un de ses films l'histoire raconte sa
conversion d'un jeune français de
tradition musulmane au catholicisme pour
l'autre l'arrivée des islamistes à
tombouctou
deux films qui ont été déprogrammés dans
certaines villes s'est racontée par
simon barbarie ce qu'il touche c'est
jésus christ fils de dieu
un jeune musulman qui se convertit au
christianisme le sujet est sensible
c'est celui du film l'apôtre réalisé et
produit par cheyenne caron un mini
budget 50000 euros
une diffusion plus que discrète moins de
dix salles en france
et pourtant la direction générale de la
sécurité intérieure a vivement conseillé
la déprogrammation du film dans une
salle de cinéma nantaise un risque
d'attentât et évoqué la projection est
annulée que c'est une juste de jésus qui
est il pour toi vraiment même message à
un cinéma de neuilly sur seine mais
cette fois ci la projection est reportée
à la mi avril
des précautions compréhensible mais en
contradiction avec les nombreux messages
sur la liberté d'expression distillées
dans la sphère publique
de plus des attentats de charlie bien
loin de la provocation l'apôtre est un
film foncièrement pacifistes ou peu à
peu catholiques et musulmans avance vers
une compréhension mutuelle timbuktu
d'abderrahmane sissako a lui aussi été
déprogrammé à villiers sur marne
le maire ump jacques alain benisti un
cru que le film sélectionné au dernier
festival de cannes faisait l'apologie du
terrorisme
peut-être aurait-il dû voir l'oeuvre
avant car elle en est tout le contraire
tout beau tout neuf à un rétropédalage
du maire s'en est suivie le film sera
finalement projeté dans une quinzaine de
jours mais escorté d'un débat avec
responsables religieux et associatifs
des précautions qu'il ya quelques
semaines encore aurait semblé bien
superflue vous pourrez maire de fréjus
seriez vous prêt à céder à des
intimidations pour déprogrammer un film
non clairement non je pense qu'il est
important que la liberté d'expression
soit totale y compris dans le monde
cinématographique non moins je peux
comprendre l'inquiétude d'un élu local
qui considère que les conditions de
sécurité ne sont pas réunies
et donc voilà c'est un sujet un petit
peu compliqué mais leur appel éclair sur
la valeur qu'est la liberté d'expression
liberté d'expression qui peut à
géométrie variable au sein du front
national puisque vous même vous avez
interdit un journaliste de l'express
d'accéder à une vo conférence de presse
à fréjus le petit journal est interdite
des congrès frontiste c'est pas quand
même deux poids deux mesures la liberté
d'expression non non pas du tout dans la
l'immense majorité de nos réunions tous
les journalistes sont les bienvenus et
vous le savez bien vous en interdisaient
certains vous êtes le seul parti
politique a changé de bord le petit
journal soient pas des journalistes
c'est du divertissement
et quand on voit si vous voulez la
manière qu'ils ont de nous traiter
je crois que en effet ça n'est pas
acceptable et quant à par exemple
mediapart que nous refusons aussi et ce
sont eux qui avaient choisi de ne pas
traiter marine le pen dans le cadre de
la présidentielle donc saint-just
retourne enfin merci
la chine d'abord commenté avec
l'annoncions l actualité de la semaine
merci michael très bonne suite des
programmes